[Music]
wait
who is mr falcon no one then why did he
say it
well in the real version he said a bad
word but they had to change it for tv
tv is so lame what did he really say
that's so much better this movie works
on a lot of levels
son of a mitch melissa cooper
what i said mitch there's nothing wrong
with that
but you meant another word i'm sorry
what other word
just watch it hold on so you're saying
if i have a friend whose dad's name is
mitch
i'm not allowed to talk about him i know
what you're doing
okay i just feel bad for my friend
that poor son of a mitch melissa cooper
why didn't you eat with us i'm not
hungry dad's mad at me
mom's not thrilled with me either why
mom made chicken and i said chickens
cluck a lot
so they should be called cluckers and
some chickens are moms
so you could call them mug care mom sure
did
what did you do wrong i got dad in
trouble with the irs
he has to hire an accountant which could
cost us a lot of money
dang makes me not want to have kids
hey hello playing with your train
i'm punishing myself by looking at them
but not allowing myself to run them
you don't have to punish yourself
because you'd rather do it that's fair
no it's okay i deserve it
actually i want you to represent us at
the altar
but i messed everything up you did
i also know if anyone's smart enough to
get us out yes you are
why'd you change your mind no reason
what did the accountant say nothing they
said my returns were perfect didn't they
play with your trains
[Music]
why are you reading the bible i felt bad
about last night so i thought it might
be good for me
where are you going with this nowhere i
just want to make you happy
and the man increased exceedingly and
had much cattle
and maidservants and men servants in
camels
and asses okay stop what i'm just
reading from genesis
well cut it out fine let's try
exodus and on the seventh day thou
shalt rest that thine ox and my ass may
rest
that is it you are grounded for reading
the bible
the way you are doing it yes go to your
room okay
i don't have a donkey but if i did i
take my ass out of here
[Music]
do
so
you